new at noon the southern nevada health  district updated its efforts to try and  get the coronavirus vaccine to children  at least at tried anti-vaccine  protesters gave an attempt to shout the  presentation down but it didn't matter  i'm like looking right in the camera  because i'm a father of two i have a  six-year-old i have a three-year-old and  this is what we've been talking about  for over a year now because this is a  scary time and for parents out there  that are wondering what to do for their  children no matter where what side you  fall on  you want to make the very best decision  for your child  city councilman brian knutson there  here's a look at some of the  demonstrations not a whole lot of people  there the health district and several  local pharmacies have started giving  vaccines to children here in the valley  we'll have more on this story coming up  tonight at 5.